I know you've been complaining but you
weren't ready Rob handlery I feel like
you've been covering grand theft auto 5
for most of 2014 just waiting for the
heights of days to finally show its
waiting turns out we're gonna be waiting
until next year well yeah early 2015 so
I guess you could say january-february
March yeah trailer came in today they
showed off some details for what were
actually gonna be able to do in heists
that's right as well as some info in
general and hype train all aboard I'm
stoked so just to kick it off they
showed a lot of stuff tons of new air
vehicles got like a hind helicopter the
hydrojet from san andreas which is like
Burke will take off you got a Huey
helicopter with mounted guns you got an
armored car tons of just kick ass
vehicles but the heist info was finally
revealed so it's going to be four people
total in hice the heist leader needs to
have a high-end apartment where you
actually conduct the as you remember in
story mode you have like those odds yeah
you have to do it in your own like cork
board stall right it's exactly that so
there's an F there's five missions each
mission has basically four ways of
playing it okay one reasons why it took
so long to get this hi sup day out is
that each person had to be doing
something interesting the whole time
yeah so instead of like single-player
where you can you know you're just
playing one character and when I switch
when the interesting stuff happens right
I guess if the getaway driver can't just
be sitting in the car waiting for
everyone one guys will be flying a point
one guy is going to be handling
demolitions one guy's gonna be
undercover like in a prisoner's him like
that I hope that they still have the
mass of people playing because they came
at wat narrow September 2013 the
next-gen version will have been out for
you know two or three months by the time
no four or five at a time they said this
hits the streets and it's probably real
interesting I think to play those for
the first time but do you imagine
because you're somebody plays GTA online
quite a lot you imagine that there's
going to be this sort of atmosphere
where people are going to be like almost
speedrunning them just getting really
really good at them and I trying to get
right teams yeah I mean think total
there's it's gonna be about 20 hours of
actual gameplay the idea also in
with GTA online is you want money so
there is you know if you do first person
for instance do all the missions first
person you get a bonus oh you're kidding
yeah that's pretty amazing and oh yeah
I'm touching back on the heist leader
which is really interesting is the heist
leader actually also does like you know
their setup missions yes to your actual
height so that's still incorporated but
the heist leader also has to throw down
money oh no my money in order to like
buy the masks by the uniforms by the you
know outfits for the mission just saying
so I'd say yeah it's and each person has
a totally different experience so pre
playing these I mean I I could see it
you know 20 hours you know tripling a
fat like I can see it being something
you'd always want to play it back on
well we've been waiting long enough to
do is your hope is that Rockstar have
been putting into the time to make sure
that it's a worthwhile update so uh yeah
I look forward to your covering myself
taste continuing on 2015 and those right
into the future on here on gamespot com
yeah
you